j'ai toutes les faits internationaux là
placé par pays Angleterre Allemagne il
possède 13000 films différents tous ont
assez dans son modeste local de l'avenue
Mont-Royal Luc major le propriétaire du
club vidéo le cinoche est un des
derniers parmi les derniers au Québec
récemment il tient bon par passion et
aussi parce que le local est à lui ses
revenus seraient insuffisants pour payer
un loyer c'est juste rentable juste
assez pour trouver les prêts on dégage
un petit profit mais ça me donne même
pas ça le minimum mais j'ai mis un
emploi moins payant que j'adore que
nappe que j'aimerais pas Luc n'a plus
d'employer et à l'exception du samedi le
cinoche est ouvert seulement soirée en
40 ans les temps ont bien changé si vous
possédez un magnétoscope qui vous aura
coûté en moyenne 900 dollars et que vous
louez 8 à 10 jusqu'à 7 de films par
semaine vous êtes un bon client de club
vidéo
si les années 80 ont marqué la belle
époque des clips vidéos les années 2000
ont signé leur mort avec les plateformes
de diffusion comme Netflix aujourd'hui
Luc accueille une douzaine de clients
par soir et connaît leur nom par cœur
mais plus en pas cher parce que je donne
une raison au client de sortir de la
maison moi je cherche des nouveautés
chez 5 dollars taxes comprises
en tant que tel de pouvoir les les voir
les toucher les regarder prendre mon
temps de voir Luc puis discuter avec lui
de toute autre chose
moi je vais essayer surtout pour des
vieux films en fin de compte mais sur la
vitrine du cinoche une pancarte à vendre
l'hiver dernier Luke en a eu marre les
distributeurs lui proposent de moins en
moins de nouveautés il y a plein de
films qui sortent en DVD comme des films
françaises j'en ai presque plus même les
films québécois il y a des titres qui
sortent plus là sauf qu'après des mois
sans offre ils sont maintenant à
transformer la moitié de son local en
petite salle de cinéma on fait un trou
dans le mur le projecteur à l'arrière ce
qui lui permettrait il espère de louer
ses films encore plusieurs années ici
jean-Sébastien Cloutier Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]